[Music]  [Music]  hmm  morning tinkers  oh no tinkles i can't  [Music]  a little privacy tinkles i swear  bad thing goes bad no no no  no  don't you have anyone else to play with  wait a second that's  it  [Music]  i have a little surprise for you  [Music]  oh don't worry what we need  is a monster dog like  [Music]  lollipop  [Music]  say hello oh booty  [Music]  he's not that weird  okay he's weird what about swampy  [Music]  next diablo  next spike  pebbles  heidi slithers sharky  whatever this thing is  next what  the last one oh boy this had better work  oh tinkles great news  i found you the perfect monster pet to  play with  say hello to your new best friend  sand  [Music]  oh it's a cat  stop  [Music]  [Music]  great now who are you going to play with  no oh no playing  [Music]  you